Britain has some of the best restaurants
in the world you couldn't have said that
10 years ago but now we've become a
nation of food lovers and restaurant
goers I want to celebrate Britain's
culinary Coming of Age by finding the
best restaurant out there so I asked you
to tell me where you love to eat out and
you told me big time we had over 12 000
nominations for brilliant places to eat
I spend months going through the
nominations with my best restaurant team
and I've chosen the best two restaurants
from your nominations in each type of
cuisine
I'm now going to put them through their
paces
[Music]
if they're going to win the title of my
best restaurant they've got a lot to
prove and if they let you down there's
going to be trouble
[Music]
tonight my brand new Nationwide
restaurant competition kicks off with
one of the world's favorite Cuisines
it's Italian
and it promises to be an incredible
battle between two very different but
equally stunning Italian restaurants
I've always loved Italian food and at
its best it really manages to transform
simple fresh ingredients into
extraordinary dishes packed full of
flavor may have the onion please Ashley
thank you
the Italians take their cooking and the
ingredients very very seriously
and they're fiercely competitive love
that passion use you sent in a huge
number of Italian nominations the two
fighting for a place in the semi-finals
of this Nationwide competition are both
exceptional casa Samir from Bristol
versus manula from London we're going to
see raw young Talent from the West
country take on a highly experienced
Chef in the capital go to war you win it
that's what we're here for
casimir's Cutting Edge Italian food will
battle it out with manuda's authentic
rustic dishes
[Music]
your ambitious young coloring Alchemists
will challenge a sicilian gastronomic
Godfather if you mess up you're gonna
get it I mean you're going in for the
high jump with me this guy's a limit you
just want to move forward and get to the
top of the game but who will come out on
top who believe you didn't make no
mistakes bring it on it's what we do I'm
going to push both these Italian
contenders the Breaking Point with three
daunting challenges I intend to test
them for the absolute limit because they
can only be one winner
the first of my two brilliant Italian
competitors is manula a truly
exceptional restaurant that fought its
way through thousands of nominations
named after the Sicilian almond is run
by 45 year old Santino who cooks hearty
authentic food inspired by the love of
his birthplace Sicily my cooking it is
all about Simplicity it's about taking
as few ingredients as possible
and making sure that the quality of
those ingredients shine
that's delicious he spent years as a
head chef at some of London's top
restaurants before opening manula a year
ago they quickly gained a loyal
following this place screams Sicily I
mean that man Cooks from the harbor
Santino is fiery and passionate
demanding nothing less than Perfection
from all these kitchen staff what the
[__] is that doing in there yeah Andy's
front of house managers Angelo and Rocco
if you've messed up you're going to get
it I mean you're going in for the high
jump with me
I'm a very competitive person I go out
to win I don't like to lose I'll put my
food against antibodies in the country
no doubt
I love Santino's competitive spirit and
is going to need every ounce of it to
handle my first pressure test because my
30 handpick guests are about to arrive
and order all at the same time if every
restaurant's worst nightmare when's the
last time you did 30 covers like that we
can do this we can do this okay I love
that level of confidence you're in new
restaurants absolutely you get on the
blog a lot to prove I'll be watching
everything I'll be like a hawk over the
dining room Rocco and here in the
kitchen as well okay
I'm giving my noodle just two hours to
produce the best meal these 30 customers
have ever eaten
importantly don't let yourselves down
yeah good luck thanks
santina's restaurant is packed I'm gonna
push the kitchen in the front of house
to the Limit and in the process give
them a chance to shine every service is
Warped
go to war you win it
that's what we're here for
um on the menu tonight is a choice of
three starters Sicilian tomato salad hot
smoked Venison and
Lobster Linguini
okay no
problems
[Music]
please that must be 14 or 16 linguine of
lobster
service has only just started and
already I can see a problem he's gonna
be the [__] in there about five minutes
time because everyone's ordering
linguine but no one's controlling it
check on takes about a quarter of an
hour to cook each Lobster linguine two
covers
put the linguine in 13 minutes linguine
if front of house don't persuade the
diners to order the simpler starters
Santina will struggle to finish service
within the two-hour time limit I want
three lobsters one two three a good
maitre d should be able to sell the
other dishes on the menu push the
risotto yes that is linguine push the
venison the Venice is delicious I'm
afraid I'm gonna have the linguine and
Scottish Lobster as well
guess what
how long for the next four linguine and
two linguine those six linguine after
that and with the clock ticking 15 is up
against it Jesus Christ I feel for him
right now in there because he's about to
explode it's like an angry you just
pulled the pin and he's gonna go any
minute now guaranteed why because he's
getting screwed upstairs they have to
help him I'm making his life a little
bit easier in there are they selling in
that delicious venison
everyone
more Lobster please thank you very much
here we go
four linguine two lobsters please get me
Rocco please
[Applause]
the risotto is delicious
four linguine Lobster just for a change
clean the place my darling here we go
two-thirds of the diners have ordered
the lobster linguine the starters have
taken an hour to leave the kitchen
I spotted a weakness here and it's not
the food
it's the nicest looks where I've ever
had it's really good the lobster was
lovely nice and spicy
[Music]
and once again Rocco has failed to sell
the two quicker dishes on the menu
everyone's gone for the beef fillets
well done for you as well what is he
playing her guys check on 3B that's one
hour gone one hour left to go left guys
one hour oh you get all those beef out
especially ones that are well done it's
a tall order we're gonna be up to it
we're going to be up to give me the
hockey three beats now
what
I just
want to do next give me some water is my
pressure test gonna bring Santina to his
knees
I swear to God I feel like I'm gonna
faint
he's in the shirt big time and it's
because of him
[Music]
I'm searching for my best Italian and
I'm putting Sicilian restaurant manula
in London's West End to the test with my
first challenge 30 customers have just
arrived and all ordered at the same time
Jesus Christ Rocco's front of house took
orders for over 20 Lobster linguine and
almost sank the kitchen now head chef
Santino's been overwhelmed by the large
number of orders taken for the main
course
he's upstairs that he's taking orders
with all the linguine on every check and
more importantly it will be will this be
free beef one medium one rare one medium
well yeah then screw the kitchen I feel
like I'm gonna fall down any minute now
I swear to God I feel like I'm on a
faint
[Music]
right let's go
Channel 9 we're not going to be late do
you understand me we are not going to be
late yes sir with just 35 minutes left
of my two hour time limit the finishing
line is in sight the last thing Santina
needs is under the front of house [__]
up
25.
they're waiting for the starter so yeah
we've been cooking for 90 minutes we
didn't send the check because we wanted
to slow down
now rocker says he's held back the order
to help the kitchen catch up but what he
really means is they're even further
behind with the service than Santino
thought come on you gotta you gotta you
have to have the balls and explain the
[__] up you can't hold a ticket back if
you do hold a ticket back he's got a
nose
you watch
we have a problem we need to fix it
let's go quickly I gotta smoke medicine
I got one more rather I've got four
linguine yeah
the bottom line is he forgot the ticket
yeah he didn't hold anything back you
forgot the [__] ticket and he's come
here and instead of being a man and said
to me with balls look Chef this happened
yeah it can happen to anyone he's come
to me and said to me and lie to me
thinking I'm stupid
something isn't this [__] I mean big
time all because of Rocco but I have to
say he's got my respect tonight because
he's encouraging those Cooks along every
ounce of the way we're nearly there come
on guys we can do this come on boys
believe it I mean if that was me in that
situation 10 years ago I would have
flipped my lead big time and pickle the
balls of Rocco turn them into [__]
I'm not losing come on move it
Santino has cooked his heart out tonight
he's only just made it to the end of
service
but for my diners his simple Sicilian
food has been outstanding I've had the
lobster start perfectly cooked really
nice bottle of chili and then had the
beef it's all ready
[Applause]
what was the menu tonight
we've
with the risotto no the menu was
linguine beef linguine beef 25 times we
had the passion the soul and food but we
didn't
match it with a service when you have a
table of six you've got to get that six
in and we waited 92 minutes before you
realized that that table was forgotten
that's not good enough Rocco look back
on it and learn that's all you can do
that's all you can do do it again and
I'll kill you right but today I won yeah
well done thank you thank you chef
[Music]
that was so intense
oh my God
it was like
the biggest rush in your life it was
just amazing I don't know what went on
with the front I was like We'll kill him
but we held it together
I got the stupid smile on my face I'm so
happy I'm so proud
[Music]
now it's time for my second Contender to
be put to the test such a wonderful
restaurant that my team and I felt it
simply had to be in the top two
this is Casimir in Bristol a fantastic
Italian restaurant now it's run by two
young brothers who today are the
youngest holders of the mission star in
Britain I've got some very very high
hopes for them in this competition
I love this restaurant because it's a
family affair
mum and dad front of house
and in the Kitchen Two Brothers creating
Cuisine unlike anything I've ever seen
in an Italian restaurant really good
presentation unique
Brothers Peter and John Ray are so
creative and experimental that frankly
they make Heston look old-fashioned
I really want to take customers through
a new experience something special and
magical what I really like about these
two guys is their energy and their
ambition they are really seriously
pushing the culinary boundaries out to
the extreme and they're still in their
early twenties you think exactly alike
because obviously there's two minds
thinking on one job they were almost
like one complete person if that makes
sense
[Music]
if you're completely Bonkers or a pair
of child Geniuses
they've got a gastronomic instinct which
can't be taught or learned
I was proud of my boys from the very
first day they were born the first step
the first smile but now what can I say
it's just the proudest father in the
world but I can see that this success
has come at a price Peter and John Ray's
culinary dreams are being funded by
every penny of their parents life
savings
we have to sacrifice our retirement
basically yeah it was a big gamble I
telling you was a big gamble
let's hope Paco's paternal faith is
going to be rewarded because Casimir are
about to face my first pressure test
I'm gonna hit them with 30 diners
Iving and ordering at the same time
okay guys everybody are there stationed
I'm like manula they have just two hours
to produce the perfect meal for my
special guests
a lot of anxiety in me so just want to
get it Go in get the server side
hopefully we don't make no mistakes
today yeah is about pressure I'll be
watching everything I'll be in the
kitchen I'll be in the dining room I'll
be missing nothing
you guys want a mission star last year
phenomenal
today raise the bar again
my 30 guests are about to experience an
avant-garde take on Italian cuisine well
they love it or wish they'd just gone
for a pizza but then let's go start
going boys
first out chicken liver pathway
very strong that Master puree you want
to be that strong it's one of the main
elements because obviously that's why we
highlight the tops yeah we like the
herbs and we just want the other things
next up beetroot risotto with pickled
fennel all nine and table seven how was
the risotto yeah very good nice and
sweet
[Music]
and bravely trout sous-vide the fish is
vacuum packed and cooked in a warm water
bath so its texture remains unchanged
[Music]
it's daring to experiment like this but
you can't alienate the customer they
need to understand what's being served
to be able to appreciate it
is the fish meant to be cooked like this
it's a bit of a strange consistency it
is it's because it's cooked in a water
bath so it keeps the texture and the
flavor and the taste right okay
um I really just don't like it to be
honest
okay I mean you can particularly
probably Hand by it but it'll actually
ruin the texture of it so happy with
that you want me to do that no no I'll
eat my peas you sure yes it is
supposed to come in here for the first
time you have to explain to them it has
very pink very very pink just yeah I'm
just I'm just observation I do still do
stops the confusion
she almost challenged me on what I was
saying rather than just accepting that I
didn't like it and I feel it wasn't
cooked properly which then made it very
hard for me to send it back
it's crucial to keep customers on side
and Mum Susan has to take responsibility
for that front of house
we're not in the 1980s and if a customer
was their fish cooked a little bit more
two seconds two minutes whatever it may
be you get it done next up Quail with
celery root puree on a pastry nest
also served very rare and again
customers should be told
[Music]
when we asked how the quail was cooked
which turned around and said well of
course somebody had to get used to and I
thought
I didn't you know I didn't really
appreciate that too much
I'm worried by how much food is coming
back uneaten just the one thing that
strikes me no one takes any food back in
the kitchen it just dumped here no one
gives these guys yeah what they always
do at the end of the evening what not
there and then well it depends if
obviously something you've said yeah so
I'm just listening I'm here to find out
how you're running a restaurant yeah
yeah fish comes back no it comes back
and no one goes back in the kitchen with
it yes I know they're your son but it
doesn't stop it from telling me the
truth
motherly love is a wonderful thing but
keeping the truth from your chefs is a
mistake
feedback from the dining room absolutely
yeah yeah when
pretty much sure most nights so most
nice yes and what kind of feedback do
you get back Peter in general normally
really positive every fence uh normally
runs really perfect perfectly smooth
I get complaints in my ration that's the
only way I've learned because you
constantly get feedback on a daily basis
not always great and blowing smoke of
each other's ass you only learn from
negatives not the positives
[Applause]
Peter and John Ray have finished service
in less than two hours and despite some
criticisms most of my guests love
casemia I thought the food was really
special really spectacular I thought the
dishes were really intricate and really
clever and really well balanced flavors
really really good you wouldn't go to
many other places and get this sort of
cooking and these sort of ideas on your
plate and the presentation is fantastic
a mission star doesn't confirm
everything you send out it's perfect if
you're trying to be avant-garde you've
got to go with your customers
you've got to take every customer
forward and like I said if she wants her
fish cooked more I cook it I cook her
trout more and if anything comes back
that's half eaten these two what they
need to know is what's wrong with it
there and then not at the end of the
night not 15 minutes later how many
chefs have you gotten to you you're
missing you're missing my points
all I want in my restaurant on a daily
basis is the negatives that makes me
better
and they're your chefs not your sons
they're your sons on your day off
this family depends on this restaurant
and it's a business it's not a
playground there's a big difference
there is a big difference well done
[Music]
it's difficult when you've got family
working together
obviously with your mother and dad run
in front of house like Gordon said
rapping and wrapping Us in Cotton walls
absolutely everything he says totally
true
there's two very talented young chefs in
there what they need now is that level
of guidance but tough love and not
having their ass kissed by their mother
tonight two brilliant restaurants are
battling to become my best Italian and
win a place in the semi-final
I've invited to London for a debrief
what they don't know is since they last
saw me I've sent secret diners into the
restaurants to see how they perform when
they're not in the spotlight and their
guard is down
[Music]
ERS are invaluable they'll catch any
restaurant off guard and I use them on a
weekly basis
food critic Simon Davies is one of the
best in the business and has judged food
and service at thousands of restaurants
Sarah Durden Robinson has worked with me
and other top chefs for years creating
and perfecting thousands of dishes
it's one thing serving easy to please
customers but how will my competitors
perform when my undercover diners are
deliberately difficult and demanding is
there any way you can turn the noise
down a bit I'm allergic to those
I can't eat sultanas
first to face the music is Sicilian
restaurant manula
[Music]
why I need to tell you now you've
actually been tested twice
I sent in
a secret Diner
the coach trip identified front of house
as manula's weak point or serifying that
manager Angelo has improved things since
my last visit
for about 10 minutes
either they're washed off their feet
and they can't cope or they've actually
forgotten right here
10 minutes
before even a menu a drink bread olive
oil it is too long you're not 10 minutes
10 bloody minutes 10 goddamn minutes to
wait
that's that's
all unacceptable what would you
recommend in your antipathy yes we've
got very nice burrata cheese very creamy
okay otherwise
so when I asked him about the um the
starters and said could you tell me what
would you recommend what's your favorite
and then he just pointed at everything
and read out what it said on the menu
which is what I've been doing for the
last 10 minutes
yeah
a lady wants your personal
recommendation she's not asking to read
the menu out again she's asking for help
hello I've just I'm just delicious but
I've just tasted his it's absolutely
fantastic can I can I change and have
that instead yes no problem do you mind
okay yeah let me check her window
manager okay thank you
Prego what's going on
Prego what's going on look at your face
he's just so delicious I wanted that one
instead
you want to leave the screen yeah yeah I
don't want the squid I want to have the
beef
yeah it's absolutely fine of course yeah
yeah no no that's fine okay sure yeah
thank you
yeah it's good it's good
that was a disaster
[Music]
have you any idea how flexible we have
to be with customers today I
deliberately put her in there to see
what level of flexibility your
restaurant has
is yes thank you
okay yeah I know it was but I tried his
beef it was so delicious I thought oh I
made a mistake
I know I'm sorry
of course thank you very much
thank you
gracious really really gracious and why
are you coming out and being 10 times
more Charming than your maitre d
AME Immaculate fantastic that squid I
had only absolutely delicious
but this the service
it's not doing Justice to what's coming
out of the kitchen
Angelo talk to me please
I remember I say I remember very well
said they was a crazy lunch so
I agree with you that many things went
wrong this day fortunately it's not
always like that
now that was a bad day we all have them
bounce back and put it right
you're more capable of doing it
there's a bit the first thing to do I
mean we're people coming in look from
the menu give the drinks
ten minutes seems to be a little bit too
long I mean a little bit it's too long
it's too long so I don't think anyway
I'm not gonna sugarcoat it it's not a
good thing no but definitely come back
from it and uh you know we're a
restaurant we're a live thing we you
know we're growing all the time we've
only just got there and we're doing
amazing amazing work every day every
service we're doing a great job
and that's why we're still in this and
we can win this I thought the trout was
slightly undercooked next it's about
this isn't it
what is about taste but they were
undercooked the team from Casimir faced
the truth from my undercover Diner it's
about taste isn't it uh excuse me
you're now going to undermine a customer
[Music]
tonight two brilliant restaurants are
battling out to become my best Italian
and win a place in the semi-final of my
Nationwide restaurant competition
now it's Bristol restaurant casimir's
turn to discover that I've been spying
on them
[Music]
you've had one
huge challenge so far in this
competition
I'm unknown to all four of you there's
actually been two tests uh-huh yeah
because no one spotted the second one
did they
well the first one was the first one was
when your game
and the second one is I don't know after
I left the restaurant
I sent my secret Diner
to your restaurant mm-hmm
and this is what you saw
[Music]
hi there hi I'm late I'm afraid I'm
sorry uh Duncan yeah
that's okay sir sorry about that no I'm
not what I want to tell you we've got
two valid trouts
thank you Simon my undercover critic is
having the trout which some of my 30
diners left uneaten slightly undercooked
and also the peas
fit like bullets
I thought the trout was slightly
undercooked I thought and the peas
peas could have done with another minute
on the bunch
that's about this isn't it
what is about taste but they were
undercooked yeah there is no debate
about that
damn it's about taste isn't it uh excuse
me you're now going to undermine a
customer
you've got to take criticism seriously
thank you
[Music]
it's cold
excuse me
yeah it's a bit cold it's a bit cold and
it's I'm afraid yeah sure yeah because
the plates the plates
thank you
[Music]
cold
a bit like a Headmaster then
what's wrong
foreign
if you're working with families it's
often very hard to be objective about
their mistakes and their errors mum and
dad as always overprotective
as parents you're not drop them off to
school anymore
the customer's King they're the ones
passing with the 55 credit the 10
courses they're the ones that want to
boast with their friends on the way back
about coming to this amazing
amazing restaurant you have to act a
little bit more humble so flowers
oh
it's a non smoking
[Music]
what's the question it's the finale
in essence I say this is a this is a
very good restaurant trying to do
excellent things
sometimes
let us judged
perhaps think about doing a tasting menu
it doesn't have 10 dishes but just has
six dishes which are fabulous that's the
problem is you remember the bad ones you
don't so much remember the good ones
[Music]
the place has the most amazing potential
yeah customer feedback is crucial
and what you've got to do is just listen
[Music]
despite the customers not by us not by
all you guys not buying food yeah but
it's always been about our customers
complain we had to we had to have a plan
how we answer to the customer Gordon say
we I treat them with cotton walls but
perhaps it's being a father but uh yeah
so we I'm gonna I'm gonna try to be a
little bit tougher and and put my my
point of view across much in a much
tougher way after enduring my coachload
of diners and the undercover team I sent
in both Manila and Casimir have survived
blooded but unbowed
now it's time for the final test as the
chefs leave their restaurants and their
front of house teams behind and go It
Alone in my kitchen I've asked them to
create a dish worthy of a place on the
menu at my free Michigan Star Restaurant
it's been an incredible journey for both
these amazing Italian restaurants
serious contenders in this competition
and all very talented chefs today I'm
going to eliminate one of them from the
competition
both chefs will cook just one course but
it'll be the most important dish of
their lives
[Music]
the final chance to prove themselves
I've got to prove what we believe in you
know the last year has been a roller
coaster ride for for me and for Dragon
Ball as well Ashley Albany Mendler then
Darkness hits us both
he lost his father I lost my brother
just for them and for us
yeah yeah oh for Mandola
yeah exactly where we want our food to
be in that Pinnacle in that freestyle
restaurant a lot of bands are seeing us
I should get it right as well I think um
we'll get everything perfect everything
just needs to be yeah we realize if our
food was to have a reach freestyle
status today it needs to have that edge
foreign
but it's not just me they have to
impress I've invited 20 highly
distinguished guests including Carlos
presenti director of the Italian
cultural Institute and Anna Del Conte
one of the most respected Italian food
writers in Britain these Discerning
diners will be served both competing
dishes and every plate must be perfect
right gentlemen
today's the day one of you will be going
through the semi-final
and sadly
one of you
will not be cooking again in this
competition
you've now got the perfect platform
to show off
every plate
is crucial
it starts now good luck
for the chefs there is nowhere to hide
they'll be judged purely on the quality
of their food
[Music]
create one dish using a classic Italian
ingredient veal
and I can't wait to see what they do
with this
okay first to get on Eminem full Vale
please your chef
up until now Santina has been let down
by his front of house but his cooking's
been Flawless tonight he's designed a
dish true to Sicilian roods Philadelphia
veal served with Summer truffles layered
potatoes girol mushrooms and a cream of
celeriac I'm going to keep it really
simple pan fry the Beetle and we're
gonna serve it with a little potato cake
which has been done with a shoulder
reveal and pot roasted braised right six
hours okay really slow what's the sauce
uh the sauce is gonna be a little
reduction on Marsala wine because we've
got lots of earthiness on the dish so I
wanted to give it an element of
sweetness like a like a dipping Chutney
almost okay all right all right this is
classic Santino he's created a robust
dish with few ingredients a beautiful
layered cake with a braised veal
delicious like a braised oxtail it's a
real sort of hearty but amazing dish
mushrooms before Dragon Ball potato
before Dragon Ball
containers now got to focus his passion
and energy into making this a winning
dish
this is absolutely everything to me
there's a lot riding on this
okay a little bit more liquid
that veal or the Truffle is delicious
but they're cooking giraffe the most
amazing mushrooms and Jackie was not
even season them there's only four
things on the plate and they have to be
done
perfectly and if the mushrooms are under
season it just destroys the whole dish
just taste those mushrooms
thank you
you've got to take to taste Giacomo yeah
everything an absolutely amazing Journal
yeah peeled by hand yeah it's sauteed
brilliantly and no salt on there
relax use your head yeah use everything
I taught yeah these sushi have to let
him down but santinas remained calm and
impressively focused
please
[Music]
boys might risk it all with something
dangerously experimental but I can see a
change in them they're veal caponata
served with sweetbreads has all the
Hallmarks of a classic Italian Dish but
knowing these boys there'll be something
more to it you wouldn't do this without
a Twist there's got to be a Twist
somewhere yeah and I'm starting to find
out where it is where's the liquid
nitrogen
they're very sensible what we've done
it's a classic this this is really being
refined so like again precise
temperature remedies from a water bath
with the sweet breads and the veil you
know we're a very refined classic really
consistent and you've got that chefy
part with the veal sweet bread yeah how
are you cooking that we've cut them in a
water bath yep 62 for two hours
yeah it's a nice crafts than it should
be just to melt in your mouth so we've
made sure when you cook them they're
cooked in the center as well yeah
some of my coach diners found Peter and
John Ray's fish and quail to
experimental I Hope they've picked the
sweet breads right for my diners tonight
please
[Music]
it's delicious
but with everything to play for the boys
are starting to panic in my kitchen
they're out their comfort zone and it's
showing
do me a favor don't slice that Veil into
your 30 seconds away from completing
that dish when you slice the veil what
happens to it starts to get cold yeah
but what comes out of it so we want
those juices
that natural flavor so you've just bust
your balls to do four stunning dishes
but slice at the very last minute yeah
olive oil
let's go come on come on come on
you can't slice the veal when you're
five minutes away from completing the
dish you want that slice when you're
seconds away from that final Magic on
that plate so they've got to get rid of
the nerves now relax compose and step up
to the plate quickly guys I know you're
used to your mum wiping your ass but I'm
not going to say that after you guys
yeah no [__] way am I clearing down
after you in my own Kitchen yes yeah
sure every time we set up a dish yeah we
clear away guys yeah that's normally my
kitchen and I'm sure it's more than
yours yeah I'm not clearing your [__]
mess
[Music]
is sensational
foreign
I'll get your mum on my back
Casimir class table Yeah I want that
last table going out exactly like the
first table service please go nice and
steady well done good job slow start
Strong Finish Well Done lay down
service is over every Diner has been
served both restaurants dishes and I'm
about to discover what my distinguished
guests thought of them starting with
casimirs nice to see you the sweet
breads were absolutely top yes
the silver the little bit for me it was
about I prefer the Casa Mia dish the
single elements were better and the mix
also was better for me nice to see you
how was it I look at that dish I can see
the boy's soul
and that brought tears to my eyes
the meat was very well cooked and I like
the combination of meat and truffle very
well done
so which one do you prefer something
obviously when you hit it it was like it
went into your mouth it was very sweet
my Diner's comments have confirmed the
level of excellence in this competition
now it's up to me to choose a winner
whatever I decide will affect the future
of both these restaurants and their
chefs I'm still confident I'm still very
very confident simpler flavors the hit
home program
that's what I do that's why I stand by
I'm not going to change what I am I
think we've done enough um you know I
mean we've sent out dishes
um in time in we've communicated we've
played it everything's cooked perfectly
we're in a totally different
environments whatever used to but loved
it absolutely loved it
only one of these two brilliant Italian
restaurants can go through to the
semi-finals it's a very tough decision
but one I've got to make
my two top Italian restaurants manula
from London and casimov and Bristol have
finished their final Challenge and for
one of them the journey is about to come
to an end
they've both proved themselves
exceptional restaurants but now it all
hangs in the balance it's time for me to
taste the amazing dishes cooked here
tonight by Santino and the Casimir
Brothers Peter and John Ray after which
I'll make my final decision
looks great and a nice clever use of
seasoned ingredients the Gyros
the summer truffles
it's delicious it's got such great
finesse but very bold flavors really
good
I absolutely love the puree it looks
quite rich but it actually tastes quite
healthy really nice if I've got one
criticism it's a braised shoulder it's
almost like braised oxtails very rich
and it sort of overpowers the potatoes
Casimir it looks dainty sweet breads
very dangerous
to serve in any restaurant
hmm
nice combination of flavor it's fragrant
that buzzer at the end has really helps
to lift it clever I've got a problem
with the rawness of the courgettes
because it's sort of spools the textures
however the meat's cooked perfectly
ricotta Works bloody brilliantly with
the sweet breads
as for me today
is that both these dishes
taste better than I tasted in their
restaurants
[Music]
so it's the moment of truth
two outstanding Italian restaurants but
only one can win a place in the
semi-final
[Music]
okay first off well done
the
Magic
and the personalities
coming through on those plates today
was fabulous Casimir whatever happens
after this competition
continue cooking food like that the
Ricotta and the sweet bread
and the fillet packed full of flavor
elegant
and that worked criticizing the dish a
lot going on there
a hell of a lot going on
the textures
were amazing
but you call Jets
were too crunchy
there's a
huge heart
in what you do and you are one focused
guy
love what you did with the Slayer puree
generous of the truffles that's you how
could I criticize the dish I thought the
shoulder
it's quite heavy but packed full of
flavor
thank you
but this competition is not going to be
won or lost on one dish alone
it will be down to this
which restaurant
would I love to return to
and eat one more meal
Casimir
you guys and your restaurants have been
under immense pressure
think back to that coach load of diners
walking in there 30 of them sitting down
it's a nightmare for any restaurants
you've been under scrutiny with secret
diners filming Undercover
I think both restaurants took the
criticism admirably and I think you
really handled
not just the positives but the negatives
as well and that's what I love to see
how you bounce back
sadly they're going to be one restaurant
going through to the semi-final
based on everything
I've seen tasted
and been part of
[Music]
the restaurant that's going through to
the semi-final
[Music]
Casimir
great job
absolutely brilliant
[Music]
manula you are a man that is on a
mission when your team is as good as you
you're going to pop big time it's been a
great experience we said before we came
in no matter what happened we'd be happy
I like to win
so that's you know that's that's the
game
congratulations
it's really job well done I didn't
expect it I didn't you know we didn't
have it it was such a tough call because
we work hard nuts off a lot of the time
and uh
you have time obviously approval from
Gordon to the next round is just
unbelievable and Mum and Dad are suck on
it
and they've sacrificed everyone
[Music]
oh no I'll be right I know um you know
mum and dad have sacrificed everything
over the last 10 years and uh as long as
everybody sticks together I think we'll
uh keep going far you know I think we're
just going to go to that next
semi-finals and knew that we can
actually move forward and get through to
the final and hopefully go on to win the
thing
that's a big voice and a heavyweight in
this contest
but I have found Casimir two young guys
that mean business and now
it's game on
Britain has some of the best restaurants
in the world you couldn't have said that
10 years ago but now we've become a
nation of food lovers and restaurant
goers I want to celebrate Britain's
culinary Coming of Age by finding the
best restaurant out there so I asked you
to tell me where you love to eat out and
you told me big time we had over 12 000
nominations for brilliant places to eat
I spend months going through the
nominations with my best restaurant team
and I've chosen the best two restaurants
from your nominations in each type of
cuisine
and now I'm gonna put them through their
paces
[Music]
if they're going to win the title of my
best restaurant they've got a lot to
prove and if they let you down there's
going to be trouble
[Music]
over the last six months my team and I
have been checking out your best
restaurant nominations all over the
country
and tonight the competition continues
was one of the Britain's most popular
Cuisines Indian
Curry is a national Obsession and these
days we all expect really high standards
from our Indian restaurants I spent a
lot of time out in India and learn for
myself what real good Indian food is all
about so tonight's restaurants are gonna
have to be bloody good to impress me
from over 2 000 Indian nominations I've
chosen what I think are the best two to
fight it out for placing the semi-finals
tonight from Bradford the curry capital
of the north it's prashard
[Music]
they're going head to head with world
famous Cuisine from a London heavyweight
the brilliant and Southall give me the
prawns come on my father was a top chef
in India he used to cook for the
maharajas this competition is gonna be
the ultimate test of both my Indian
contenders it'll be a battle to the very
end because only one restaurant can come
out on top
to find that winner both contenders will
face free challenging tests starting
with a coachload of 30 hungry diners
who'll arrive and order all at once
first they'll descend on the Patel
family who run tiny pressure in Bradford
there are over 60 Indian restaurants
alone in this fantastic City but this
one is somewhat special the smallest
restaurant in this competition but I
think is going to give the big boys a
serious Run for the money
hello Bobby hi Gordon good to see you
welcome to see you very well thank you
yeah
[Music]
I've never had a vegetarian restaurant
in the competition so I'm so excited
yeah I'm happy as well yeah in just
under half an hour my Danny's gonna be
here they think they're coming for an
amazing lambuna so convert them this
place used to be a laundrette
now it's a 22 seat restaurant run by
cauti Patel with her son Bobby and his
wife Minal
what we put passion into other
restaurants offer us a side dish we have
to really step up we really have to
bring the flavors out give them
something totally different incredibly
Minal the head chef had never cooked
professionally until she married Bobby
moved to England and joined his mum in
the kitchen six years ago
she is not my daughter-in-law she's my
daughter
I can describe how much I love cooking
whatever I cook it from my heart that's
delicious one mouthful of that I feel
like I'm back in Mumbai the exact same
for my diners please no I can't leave
that to waste I've got to eat some more
of that I'm sorry Jesus we have huge
Drive huge ambition we didn't come into
this business thinking we're gonna make
loads of money we came into the business
about showing the world how good we are
at food
now they must prove it
because my 30 diners are just minutes
away they're all expecting a perfect
meal and everyone must be served in just
two hours the pressure's on you big time
and I know this means a lot I can see it
on your face but here's your chance now
to really stamp your whole in this
competition good luck
hairs on the back of my neck are
standing up right now
[Music]
all right ladies and Gentlemen let's
show the world war Prasad really is
let's rock let's show Ramsay let's go
Ramsay's best restaurant Bring It On
to accommodate my yes Bobby had to
squeeze an extra eight seeds into the
tiny dining room sorry a little bit of a
small restaurant but the food is
fantastic I promise you despite its size
Prichard has huge Ambitions to fly the
flag for vegetarian Indian cuisine
I'm in a vegetarian restaurant yes let's
hope it's a memorable experience
I'm a confirmed carnivore so anything
without me isn't really classed as a
meal my diners I'm gonna be a hard crowd
to please
and it'll take a massive team effort to
convert them okay here we go I need two
persons and I need
like the new girl on the Block and I'm
just hoping that she can cope with such
a demand because she's the least
experienced
starter she's serving coconut pities
potato and chickpea chat and spicy
vegetable pakoras for me leave that one
make the chat first
the heart service of their lives
she may be inexperienced but me now's
got to drive this kitchen like never
before
but however hard me now pushes our team
they're barely able to keep up and this
is just the first course I
push it just listen what I'm saying
you can tell it's being put together
all of them say a fantastic food really
really happy thank you thank you very
much halfway there keep it going guys
yes big push on the main courses now
yeah
but the mains will be even harder every
deep fried Curry and dose of pancake
needs to be precisely timed only one
hour left so you know I'm getting
panicked
[Music]
Prasad small kitchen is going hell for
leather but these dishes just aren't
leaving fast enough
how long do they normally wait between
courses roughly uh
uh 10 minutes yeah for the kitchen the
size they can only cook at such a speed
yeah you've got one Grill
the three large tables now waiting for
many courses yeah
[Music]
the pressure's really on and some diners
have been waiting for an hour just to
let you know guys that um this afternoon
obviously we have all 30 guests in at
once there may be a little bit of a wait
for your Mains I hope you can be patient
with it yeah
I just said be patient but she's fine
it's understandable so I'm still having
a good time
I've explained to them they're fine
about the fact that it'll be a little
while but obviously there is a deadline
on how much time we've got to serve oh
yeah somebody passed the booty please
hurry up now there's great Synergy there
between the dining room and the kitchen
and they're working really well together
they're supporting each other through
every place
come on hurry up take this hurry up now
[Music]
last four main courses yes yes
the main courses have been been delayed
but Bobby's Charming the dining room has
kept the customers on side and averted a
crisis a little thing you can make trick
things interesting
absolutely delicious lightly spiced
hotter in the center it's lovely
even the most Ardent carnivores have
been converted
amazing presentation and then the taste
itself was it lived up to how it looked
but sometimes I think it was even better
than it looked you know so I think I
think we'll try and come here again
service is over
bye-bye take care and it's time for the
Prasad team to hear my verdict
okay
um
let's cut to the chase
the the problem I have
witnessed the service is that you've
you've now
just completely
and I mean really completely
blown open this whole competition
because it runs it you've raised the bar
Bobby the communication and making sure
that customers not agitated waiting for
food you're there
and it sounded amazing me now I was
nervous about youth but that first
ticket came on and you were just on fire
thank you and you've made 30 of my
diners
the happiest I've ever heard them
[Applause]
do not go backwards no no you maintain
an improve on what you've got
good job
that you're one of the best restaurants
an amazing standard of Vegetarian
Cuisine it's going to take some beating
next is the turn of prashad's Challenger
one of London's biggest and best Indian
restaurants the Brilliance two tables in
45 minutes it's a joke please please get
a move on please this is not brilliant
[Music]
my coachload of 30 diners are about to
descend on the second Indian restaurant
battling for a place in the semi-finals
of my Nationwide restaurant competition
it's the brilliant in London voted for
by you in droves it's been open for 37
years that's almost as long as I've been
around it has three generations of
customers and any Russian that can boast
that must be doing something absolutely
spot on
family have been running this Punjabi
restaurant for 40 years with dipna
Shankar and Dad Gulu at the helm this is
a huge ship and to be right amongst the
best it just encourages us more and more
to do even better
these days good is retired from the
stove leaving the Brilliance Kitchen in
the hands of head chef jazz
all the ingredients all the meats
they're cooked freshly piping hot served
to the customers within seconds the
brilliant is known for its parts of it I
don't want people waiting for more than
five or six minutes you walk in here you
taste the food and you really start to
believe they've earned their place
as a front runner of Indian food in this
country
boasting 220 seats 28 years in the good
food guide and over 80 Awards the
brilliant is an Indian heavyweight
delicious
[Music]
pretty good
excellent I'm happy yeah
about to hit them with my first
challenge like prashad they'll also have
just two hours to serve my 30 diners who
will arrive in order all at once
it takes some balls to call it the
brilliance
you can't be anything less than less
than brilliant absolutely on a
nightlight tonight absolutely yeah
yeah we are very confident we've got
only 30 diners we're gonna make sure
these guests have a fantastic experience
made this a brilliant service hi Jazz
yeah yeah
right how's it sounding really good yeah
what are you thinking of having prawns
and a chicken nice on the menu tonight
are two of the house Specialties lamb
chops marinated in nutmeg and cardamom
and King prawns with fresh herbs and
lime juice both cooked in the
traditional Tandoor oven um
but I'll go for the prawns two abortions
Tandoori lamb chops and two Tandoori
prawns
but I'm worried HF jazz is only using
one of the kitchen's two Tandoor ovens
one Tandoori lamb chop and already
Tandoori orders are racking up three
prawns one lamb chops
come on guys let's go Sunil
you get a move on yeah please is there a
problem with the tando oven
why are we using two of us
it is now but not the beginning that's
what I'm trying to say okay guys please
please get a move on please this is not
brilliant
come on guys please when I need this out
from here come on how long for the first
time chops please okay good
it looks like it's been half eaten have
you got another one that looks a little
bit better okay the thing is they have
given the cuts
if I start eating that and I go to that
it looks like someone's taking a bite
out of it I'm only saying it for you you
can say no Gordon that's how I'm sending
it's fine okay give me one more piece of
Lamb Chop please I'm not trying to catch
you out yeah I'm just saying that that's
not you at your best
friends
that looks beautiful thank you so much
two tables in 45 minutes it's a joke
100 settings 30. we should have been
finished by now
using just one Tandoor oven has slowed
service to a crawl and orders just
aren't getting out
there why can't you go with that yeah
there's more than one way through the
kitchen come on serve the food Alexis
please please please
there you go come on
come on
I need the prawns why are they going in
the oven where the cook they should be
gone
help me to understand you
[Music]
how we are because we've been waiting
for now okay
it's got to be the longest time I've
ever sat in a restaurant without being
feds
it's an unwelcome wake-up call for owner
an ex-head Chef Gulu
his kitchen needs leadership and Jazz
looks lost
the Russian's reputation hangs in the
balance
Julie's got his jacket on
okay I need the prawns plates no prawns
in your plates I want it straight away
in the area hurry up boys
get me the prawns are the prawns ready
yeah give me the prawns come on straight
straight head
s
succulent full of flavor
let's try and finish
okay next I need four methi chickens eat
them piping hole
[Music]
a lot more energy in the kitchen now the
more importantly the old men's in there
so he's gonna put a rock up their ass
table number five the dishes are there
now we're
fired up yeah
yeah
we've solved everybody
[Music]
it was far from a perfect start but for
my diners the food has really hit the
mark
wow gorgeous
food smells amazing
my fear is absolutely delicious I
normally go for the standard like creamy
curries
um but this was something completely
different and I specifically asked for
it to be mild up and they did it to
Perfection it was stunning brilliant
that was absolutely Divine
it's probably the best Curry I've ever
had really really delicious I'm glad you
enjoyed it
[Music]
I love this rations 40-year pedigree but
tonight they've only got it together
after a chaotic start okay
low starters took too long to leave this
kitchen
30 covers tonight felt like 300 covers
it was a little bit too casual but still
it takes time
right from the scratch not good enough
this restaurants is not used to sending
out mediocre warm prawns you take a
prawn from that Tandoori Oven and you
stick it in there
game over
you've got to command that kitchen Jazz
from the house
main causes needed a rocket yeah you put
your jacket on bang and it turned yeah
and the kitchen came to life and there
he was the old man at the helm and here
we go again there was that a fire in
your belly and you got it out don't get
pissed off no no I'm not get eager to
come back well you're gonna be even more
stronger now thank you good night
it was a bit bit of a shock to the
system yeah we can still win this we can
we will win this okay good well done
[Music]
my Indian restaurants reacted very
differently to the pressure of the coast
trip now I've asked them both to come to
London so I can catch up with them
what they don't realize is that I've
been assessing them secretly I send in
my own undercover diners to prashard and
the brilliant to see how each restaurant
performed when they have no idea I was
watching and their guard was down
Davis is a meticulous food critic who's
assessed the food and service at
thousands of restaurants
Sarah Durden Robinson has worked with me
in other top chefs for years helping to
create and perfect thousands of dishes
secret diners are a very useful trick of
the trade and they give you honest
immediate feedback and No Holds Barred
I've asked Sarah and Simon to be
deliberately awkward customers to see
how the restaurants cope
[Music]
so why should I eat it
the teams think they're here to discuss
their performance with my 30 diners they
have no idea what I'm about to show them
first up Bradford's pashard
[Music]
food was brilliant
the problem I have now
is that was that just done for me or
does that restaurant function like that
every day every day
how can you say that because we do it
every day we passionately do it every
day so yes we know is uh what we're
doing is a good because our customer
tell us that was a big test
you've actually been tested twice
after I left I sent in a secret Diner
and they secretly filmed
everything
filmed
[Music]
do you need a reservation or can we just
have some lunch yeah we okay
you can you give me a steer on what to
have yeah I can't really decide what do
you fancy well I'm feeling quite hungry
hungry yeah I'm feeling quite hungry uh
things not to miss if you're sharing
would be Pettis and would be charged and
where's this is this mainly Southern
India no this is
uh no no
okay knowledgeable great
first interaction with the diners the
food will speak for itself you know we
have that as a given so it's up to me to
kind of make that person feel
comfortable if they have questions to
answer them openly and with as much
information as they can give so let's
try one of these should we go
award-winning tattoos first
that coconut it's really clever that to
eliminate that probably it's 20 30
seconds again it's tasting different
flavors are still coming through
I'm just gonna
swap a curry quite late in the day
um and see what they do excuse me if I
change one of my curries could I is that
right any goes any any vegetable handy I
think yeah bags
good guy I couldn't have dealt with that
better
could ask you could say that this one do
we have a bit more punch in this one
let's see if he can play around with
that there's anything you can do to make
that one a little bit hotter a little
bit a little bit hotter yeah how hot do
you want it we're not not to the degree
that you know you just laugh at us when
we walk out the door
[Music]
I came back like a fresh dish
no hassle at all it's so refreshing to
see that level of flexibility there's no
intimidation you're not making them feel
awkward there's no guilt if I if I
hadn't have behaved that way in front of
my customers I know two people in the
kitchen would have been very angry at me
[Music]
burrito you know it's blowing me away
really it's been really fantastic fresh
well sourced
expertly done and done with passion and
knowledge
we'll find
pretty well done thank you you made me
feel nervous because you raised the bar
so high but I didn't think you could do
that again
oh my God don't leave it
well don't know
I'm feeling fantastic you know um Gordon
Ramsay big big man
um telling me that you know everything
we're doing is good we were nervous
before uh just can't contain it
so far prasada punching way above their
weight but I have concerns over how much
this tiny Russian depends on Bobby's
front of house charm
next is the Brilliance turn to get a
tricky customer it's too spicy now and
both teams feel the pressure as they're
pushed to the limit in a final cook-off
at my Flagship restaurant far away
please it's four listen to me listen to
me I'm here I'm here to help you you're
confusing yourself not me
tonight two fantastic Indian restaurants
are battling out in my Nationwide
competition to find my best restaurants
now it's time for London restaurant the
brilliant to find out I've been snooping
on them
unknown
to all of you once I left the brilliant
I then sent in
my secret diners and this is what they
saw
the coach trip head chef Jazz failed to
take control of the kitchen and at times
the food suffered onigulu had to step up
to the Tandoor to save the day have the
brilliant learn from their mistakes
[Music]
it's very distracting it's like in a pub
when they've got the television on and
everyone has that way
I don't know if I'm in a nightclub or a
restaurant is there any way you can turn
them turn the noise down a bit thank you
oh God that's so much better than
service
um whose idea is all those screens and
the music they've been around for quite
a while and some customers actually like
them are quite adapted to the idea but
then you do obviously get a clash
sometimes and when when we are asked we
do mellow it down
[Music]
two minute Chutney it's fantastic it's
mouth-watering so fresh it's absolutely
delicious these chutneys are really
great so many different things so many
different flavors that really gets your
palette and your appetite going nice
really good start fresh clean chutneys
exciting vibrant and a really nice way
of relaxing customers really nice way
why
yeah
that'll be the real test
hello thank you
something's just come out of the tando
they should be sizzling and clumps and
juices and these are just lit they are
definitely still
overcooked
uh Jazz prawns white they're coming out
overcooked still
as soon as we take the prawns out
quickly served in I'd ask you to look at
that seriously in terms of attempting to
cook them less I think what we need to
do is every portion of prawns that goes
out this this week do one extra prawn
and test it before it goes out because
that's something that we need to work on
I'm about to send them
to see what I say but I'm going to say
it's not spicy enough
I want to see what they do
hello set all the money that it was
spicy since which is spicy it's wet
because I like really cropped food
it's very mild hook would it be possible
to have the same thing but otter
thank you very much thanks
[Music]
customer's always right that's what
they're paying for you can adapt to the
customer's needs great
didn't start well but cut to the end of
the meal and I am so happy and I don't
think they could have looked after me
any better I don't think they've handled
my constant complaints any better I
don't think they could be more
professional the food is outstanding
when the food arrives they love the food
when the service matches the food you
have something quite exciting there
Jazz I want you to step up to the mark
I need to do something
I think I'm a bit nervous right now but
later on I'm going to develop the
confidence that was valuable feedback
that was absolutely amazing we've got to
be so positive to make sure that we
learn from the mistakes my undercover
evidence has hit them hard now they need
to learn from this experience there's no
time to waste because both restaurant
chefs are about to face their biggest
challenge yet
[Music]
them out of their kitchens and into mine
I've asked them to create and cook a
dish that lives up to the standards at
my three Michelin starred restaurant
very nice I'm very very very exciting
today to cooking in the Gordon Ramsay's
restaurant I'm putting her my hundred
percent thought in it it's a dream for
every Chef to cook for a three-style
restaurant and I'm looking forward in
winning this completion tonight one of
them will win a place in the semi-finals
and one will be eliminated
this is my dream here everything I've
ever worked for it's a small beautiful
restaurant and it's an amazing place for
both of your restaurants today to really
shine I asked you to come here to take
it to a different level with your foods
and really aspire to do something unique
at the end of it sadly there's only one
restaurant that's going through the
semi-final
make sure it's you good luck oh
[Music]
to create one Exquisite course
big amount of pressure on their
shoulders today because they've got to
develop and evolve those dishes into
something stunning I'm expecting a dish
that's perfectly spiced with delicious
textures and Sublime flavors
but it's not just me they have to
impress I've invited 20 guests who know
their barges from their biryanis to come
and try both restaurants dishes
including enam Ali founder of the
British Curry Awards and respected
Indian cookbook author and broadcaster
Manju Mali all my diners will try both
restaurants dishes
each restaurant's front of house teams
are here as my yes and I'll be watching
the chefs every move and there's nowhere
to hide
supposed to get on it's for the
Brilliance at four covers away Table Six
yeah four gel crazy
[Music]
tonight the brilliant are taking on
Prasad at their own game cooking a
vegetarian take on a much loved classic
paneer gel Frazee Jazzy's recipe matches
chili Laden Indian curd cheese with a
sauce flavored with a unique blend of 15
spices
I'm making my own cheese today wow isn't
that a bit crazy on a day like today
Chef I'm in your restaurant I have to do
something crazy this is the type of
flourish Jazz needs to lift this classic
dish to new heights opportunities like
these never knocked on your doors that's
the reason why I'm working so hard I
want to achieve something today
and I'm excited to see sous chef Sunil
making a specialty rarely found in the
UK paper thin ramali roti
[Music]
guys look at me just like a normal
restaurant I need an answer right well
you don't answer me I'm just going to
stop and look at you again okay because
like you do in your kitchen you get a
response but I'm calling out tickets and
no one's responding just acknowledge
what I'm saying right otherwise I'll
just go like this [__] it stick the
tickets up there and I gotta call it out
for gel Frazee thank you welcome back
so far in this competition HF Jazz has
produced some stunning traditional
Punjabi Cuisine for the brilliant but on
occasion he's lost control of the
kitchen his food has missed the mark and
onugulu has had to save the day you got
no Gulu in the kitchen today you don't
need him in the kitchen do you no well
you've got your work cut out the heat's
on yeah this is the biggest moment in
our history of the brilliant tonight the
hopes and dreams of the brilliant rest
on Jazzy's shoulders
let's go thank you
the first dish coming from brilliant
thank you
it smells good I like the paneer nice
and softer
the Chili's got a kick wow
if I can see you then I know it's thin
enough
table five four stunning kofta yes yes
I'm making vegetable kofta steamed and
spiced chopped vegetables encasing a
potato Patty deep fried then served in a
fresh tomato sauce
[Music]
put those coffees in there too early
because it's starting to break up a
vegetable Costa is very hard to get
right I've got so many elements they can
explode and sort of disintegrate getting
the timing right on this dish is
critical so manal and kaushi need to
work together perfectly for me I bet
this is lovely because you need to be
bit pasta I am fastly look at here what
are you doing come on give me a time how
long just a minute in our own kitchen
manal struggle with the pressure and
only just came out on top and tonight
there's no supportive husband Bobby in
the kitchen to help her by now I'm
pretty sure if I know minnow and my mom
they'll be right in the middle of the
cooking and just totally focused on
giving you the best food
[Music]
but this is my kitchen and manel's way
out of a comfort zone hey anybody seen
my onion it was here
look at me after every table we have to
tear down we can't continue working in a
mess yeah thank you look after your
ingredients yeah come on Mom can I help
that please do you have some more batura
come on guys oh God come on ladies what
are you looking for
what are you looking for me now Joey
please yeah I need one more but whatever
thank you so let's go let's go please no
it's four that's it four don't worry
about that it's four listen to me listen
to me I'm here I'm here to help you
you're confusing yourself not me far
away please thank you
it's a very very lot of pressure we and
mom were going through a lot of race a
lot to do it's a very complicated dish
so it's mid time so that's why I'm I'm
just
panicking
so vegetable kofta looks amazing table
three please how is everybody very happy
this is very very good it's a lovely
shape the presentation is immaculate and
beautiful looking it's really nice isn't
it last out what policeman out Kelsey
four cops are away nice very nice
little clue down both of you well done
[Music]
oh so hot
service is over so it's time to discover
what my distinguished guests thought of
both restaurants dishes starting with a
brilliant really good to see you let's
talk the Jeff Rosie how was that for you
combination is very good also the paneer
also I found is tasty it's not only the
cheese it has good spice yes
presentation also remarkable ramadi roti
that's very very traditional this is
very hard to make I was really nervous
I'm now relieved they've done a fabulous
job
and delicious and you could taste the
fresh ginger so that was great it looked
good as well I think the prashan dish is
awesome the only thing I'd say rice is
supposed to be nice and fluffy and
separate and all they've got somehow
they've got this bit wrong right but
overall I think this is excellent
phenomenally proud the dish that they've
made today you know I definitely think
that we've done our very best
my diners clearly love the food though
neither restaurant quite achieved
perfection
now it's up to me to choose a winner
whatever I decide will affect the future
of both these restaurants if I lose
today I will be broke down I need to win
I really need to win this competition
but I don't know I'm so funny it's
definitely going to win I think we gave
over a full hundred percent into it and
we are happy we are fighting we are
happy about why I think we have done a
good job only one Indian restaurant can
go through to the semi-finals and after
tonight's service the decision is going
to be tougher than ever
my two top Indian restaurants the
brilliant from London and Prasad from
Bradford have completed their final
challenge
they are both exceptional restaurants
but one of them is about to be
eliminated
to help me make my choice I'm going to
taste each of their dishes
[Music]
it's a very difficult one to get around
those vegetables
bound with a potato and that rich tomato
gravy the downside a little bit of
fapping around unnecessary on the plate
I'd rather see one big stunning one as
opposed to three individual ones
cut in the middle you can see those
vegetables
oh my God
pretty tasty the right amount of heat
and that nice textured kofta rice
shame the rice actually lets it down
it's um it's overcooked
they're brilliant
gel Fraser Chili's everywhere
red and green chili
and the secret of this shelf crazy is
the the texture and the balance of the
Heat
they've got the heat correct in the
Masala it definitely needs that right to
cool it down paneer delicious
handmade and made here and that takes a
lot of skill the only issue I have there
is the the rawness the vegetables those
crunchy peppers are sort of spoiling the
texture of the joffrezi both restaurants
felt the pressure here today and both of
them haven't hit it 100 percent
no they've fallen short of the last
hurdle both restaurants
[Music]
two outstanding Indian restaurants but
only one can win a place in the next
round
[Music]
okay
first of all
that was a very
interesting service
I could identify issues
from both restaurants
in a way that I didn't expect
from brilliance
sumptious
delicious
finding that balance with the masalas is
a tough one
love the way you had the balls to make
that premiere
the one issue I had was the
the rawness of the vegetables the
peppers were barely cooked and it didn't
completely spoil the dish but it didn't
enhance it
prashad I thought the koftas were a bold
move loved the vegetables inside
delicious the gravy was seasoned
beautifully and had that right amount of
heat the big shock for me was the
the overcooked rice
I've eaten in your restaurant and I know
how well you cook and I didn't expect to
see overcooked rice today
this competition is not going to be won
or lost on one dish alone
I'm looking for the best restaurant in
Britain
brilliant
I turn up with a coach load of diners 30
of them jumping into the restaurant
eager to taste that food
we got off to a sluggish stars but my
God
did those diners enjoy that food I send
in my secret diners and again I've never
seen a restaurant so
excited to help one is not even their
faults good sign
[Music]
Prasad I turn up
in the back of Beyond of Bradford 30
diners could have barely fit in the
pressure was immense
however
they love the food
then I sent in my secret Diner and
peeled up the food
[Music]
this is a a tough one
a very tough one
sadly
there's only one restaurant going
through to semi-final
the restaurant going through
based on everything
I've seen and tasted
[Music]
Prasad
[Applause]
[Music]
well done that restaurant will continue
being unique there's no two ways about
that and that was for me one of the
tightest and the closest decisions I've
ever had to make
he never journey of 35 years we've won
numerous Awards and
we'll be we'll be back again right the
show carries on and the brilliant will
carry on congratulations
thank you thank you well done are you
okay really well done and I'm so happy
thank you for the family and for the
restaurant why because the food is
extraordinary thank you thank you thank
you well done thanks very much I'm so
happy I can't even think about it so
happy I'm so happy it was really
difficult for me because I wasn't in
there every single step of the way as a
family whenever we perform we're always
together service kitchen everything
together today I had to sit back and
look like I was eating enjoying food I
didn't have an appetite at all but you
know we're just I can't I can't tell you
fantastic what an extraordinary day and
I'm quite sad to say goodbye to
brilliant but you've got to give it up
for Prasad they were amazing now the
competition really starts for them
they're through the semi-finals and they
are going to have to really really pull
stops out
foreign